[Aplausos]
[Música]
el break sites como la wikipedia nos ha
pasado alguna vez que estáis leyendo un
artículo de la wikipedia que os lleva a
otro y luego a otro y seis horas más
tarde estáis leyendo sobre la
reproducción de las tortugas y os
preguntáis pero como he llegado hasta
aquí pues el presi desparecido es más
los medios llevan tanto tiempo hablando
del break sí que algunos ya lo han
convertido en un verbo de uso cotidiano
existe a decir adiós a todo el mundo en
una fiesta y después quedarse y la
pregunta que todos nos estamos haciendo
ahora es pero por qué reino unido no se
ha marchado ya de la unión europea
porque llevan tanto tiempo discutiendo
puede parecer poca cosa pero londres y
bruselas llevan ya tres años negociando
un acuerdo y todavía no parece que haya
una salida clara incluso existe la
posibilidad remota de que reino unido
celebre un nuevo referéndum y no lleguen
a marcharse nunca
[Música]
hablamos de un tema tan complejo que
tenemos que llamar a todo un experto en
praxis
si hablamos de karim al que vive en
bruselas y tiene un canal de youtube
donde ha entrevistado a la flor y nata
de la política europea o la fonseca y un
saludo a toda la gente de visual
política que estoy seguro de que todos
estamos todavía un poco confundidos con
el presi que está pasando exactamente
donde están estancados porque reino
unido sigue todavía en unión europea y
sobre todo de quienes la culpa es de
londres es de bruselas o de nadie en
particular hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
un divorcio imposible el 23 de junio de
2016 reinó unido- organizó un referéndum
con una pregunta muy clara debería reino
unido- seguir siendo un miembro de la
unión europea el 51 8% de los votantes
dijo que no o más bien dijo lee muchos
piensan que un 18 por ciento de
diferencia no es suficiente para tomar
una decisión tan drástica otros dicen
que la democracia es así pero lo cierto
es que desde el punto de vista legal el
break si te es mucho más sencillo de lo
que parece
[Música]
por compararlo con algo parecido españa
y cataluña en este caso la constitución
española no reconoce el derecho a la
secesión y por eso hay tantísimos
problemas legales sin embargo reino
unido- ni siquiera tiene constitución
con lo que técnicamente todo es posible
si lo aprueba el parlamento y la
legislación europea también reconoce el
derecho a salirse de la unión lo tenéis
aquí mismo atentos
todo estado miembro podrá decidir
salirse de la unión de acuerdo con sus
propios requerimientos constitucionales
tratado de la unión europea artículo 50
dicho de otra forma que técnicamente
reino unido podría haberse marchado de
la unión europea hace mucho tiempo no
necesitan ningún acuerdo y todo esto
sería perfectamente legal
el problema pues que sería un cataclismo
económico sin un acuerdo especial reino
unido- comerciar ya con la unión europea
bajo las reglas comunes de la
organización mundial del comercio esto
significa montones de controles
aduaneros y montones de aranceles y ya
sé lo que me vais a decir pero y dónde
está el problema fonseca a ver australia
también tienen muchos aranceles con
europa y no parece que les vaya tan mal
pues si tenéis razón lo que pasa es que
australia y europa apenas tienen
relación entre ellos sin embargo la
mitad de las exportaciones del reino
unido- van a europa si de repente a todo
esto le ponemos aranceles adiós muy
buenas todas las empresas británicas
entrarían en crisis y casi todas las
euro
p as también tendrían problemas
[Música]
pero no sólo eso la unión europea
también lo pasaría muy mal porque
principalmente por los presupuestos por
ejemplo el presupuesto europeo de
agricultura no se negocia año tras año
se negocia por periodos de seis años es
decir en 2014 bruselas sacó un
presupuesto de agricultura que va hasta
el año 2020 el dinero de ese presupuesto
lo aportan los estados miembros y en el
año 2014 reino unido- pertenecía a la
unión además era uno de los principales
contribuyentes y ahora dicen que se
quieren ir europa le dice vale muy bien
vale que os vayáis pero es que en 2014
os comprometí estéis a pagar x 1.000
millones de euros nosotros ya hemos
hecho nuestros cálculos y contamos con
ese dinero no podéis dejar de pagarlo
[Música]
así que exacto el hecho de que reino
unido se vaya de europa tiene un coste y
por eso tanto londres como bruselas
necesitan llegar a un acuerdo ahora la
cuestión es qué tipo de acuerdo y aquí
es donde llega el primer problema porque
el referéndum del break si lo que hizo
fue polarizar a la población de reino
unido básicamente se quedaron divididos
entre los roe remain es decir los
querían quedarse en la unión europea y
los progres y los que querían irse y la
primera víctima de esta polarización fue
el primer ministro de reunido por aquel
entonces david cameron este hombre lo
que propuso es que si su partido los
conservadores
ganaban las elecciones generales de 2016
pues propondría un referéndum de
permanencia o no en la unión europea
aunque ojo él siempre se mostró en
contra de la opción de brasil por ello
cuando el resultado del referéndum fue
del presi cameron decidió dimitir y se
organizaron primarias en su partido a
los que también se les conocen como los
tories y salió elegida esta mujer
3a me dice que break sí significa éxito
y que no intentará quedarse dentro de la
unión europea y como solemos decir en
visual político dicho y hecho nada más
llegó a downing street- theresa may
activo el artículo 50 y a partir de
entonces la ley dice que tiene dos años
para negociar un acuerdo con bruselas
para salirse de europa en principio todo
parecía que iba según lo acordado pero
para asegurarse el apoyo del parlamento
británico may decidió convocar nuevas
elecciones pensarlo bien esta mujer
había llegado al gobierno sin que la
votaran los ciudadanos sólo con una
votación parlamentaria además las
encuestas daban pronósticos muy buenos
para su partido para los conservadores
así que en junio de 2017 main convocó
unas elecciones generales y este fue el
resultado
[Música]
ingresá me pierde la mayoría absoluta en
el parlamento británico tal cual como lo
es la jugada de meis salió rana tanto es
así que para conseguir mantenerse en el
gobierno tuvo que hacer un pacto con un
partido minoritario el llamado dup y que
defienden estos del tup pues lo vamos a
ver más tarde pero quedamos con su
nombre el dup porque es muy importante
el caso es que con un parlamento menos
conservador que antes may tuvo que irse
a bruselas a negociar y en unos días
salió con un acuerdo bajo el brazo la
unión europea estaba muy contenta con
las condiciones teresa may también
estaba muy contenta solo faltaba un
último trámite que le diera el visto
bueno su propio parlamento y que creéis
que pasó aprobaron el acuerdo no lo
aprobaron pues el resultado es que me
sufre una derrota histórica es que
prácticamente nadie votó a favor de su
acuerdo de hecho lo peor de todo era que
incluso dentro de su partido hubo una
división brutal la mitad de los
diputados tories votaron en contra de mí
y os preguntaréis que cuál era el
problema qué pasaba exactamente en este
acuerdo pues para entenderlo tenemos que
hablar de los tomates si habéis oído
bien vamos a hablar de tomates atentos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
principiando versus presi duro
muchos podremos pensar y dar por hecho
que todos los tomates en todo el planeta
son iguales pero no es así en europa la
regulación en cuanto a la agricultura es
bastante estricta con esto y prohíbe que
se vendan tomates transgénicos estas
regulaciones están bien o mal es un tema
que da para otro vídeo pero lo cierto es
que europa básicamente tiene unas
regulaciones muy estrictas a la hora de
tratar con productos transgénicos y
estas regulaciones
evidentemente afectan a todos los
estados miembros de la unión europea por
igual esto conlleva a que un agricultor
de españa de murcia de mi tierra por
ejemplo pueda comercializar sin mayores
problemas a la hora de exportar tomates
pues alemania a bélgica oa república
checa
digamos que como los transgénicos están
prohibidos en la unión europea pues
ningún estado de la unión tiene el miedo
de acabar comprando por error estos
productos pero ahora viene el problema
y en argentina los tomates transgénicos
están permitidos imaginad que españa
hiciera un acuerdo de libre comercio con
argentina
de repente podrían comprar tomates
transgénicos y como españa está en la
unión europea podríamos tener a un
agricultor español que compra estos
tomates argentinos que están modificados
genéticamente y después va y los venden
a alemania como os podéis imaginar esto
es un riesgo no sólo para los tomates
sino para todos los productos que os
podáis imaginar
y precisamente por eso europa no puede
permitir que sus países miembros hagan
tratados de libre comercio con quien les
dé la gana pero esperad porque no hemos
terminado hay muchos países de europa
que no están en la unión europea pero
que sí que tiene acuerdos de libre
comercio con la unión europea de hecho
tres ejemplos muy concretos son noruega
islandia y liechtenstein estos tres
países como decía no están en la unión
europea pero sí que pueden vender a la
unión europea con facilidad esto en la
práctica supone que por ejemplo los
españoles podemos comprar salmón noruego
sin mayor problema y para que esto
ocurra noruega tiene que seguir en parte
las regulaciones de la unión europea
aunque en noruega no estén europea y no
decida cómo se conforma está
políticamente tiene que seguir parte de
las políticas que se toman en la unión y
aquí es donde está el gran problema
porque lo que proponía theresa may se
parecía mucho a lo que tienen los
noruegos a esto lo llamamos un break
shit blando es decir si vale nos vamos
de europa pero mantenemos todas las
regulaciones y como os podéis imaginar
los 'breaks' y ter os dijeron
nosotros hemos votado break sheet para
no tener que seguir las leyes de
bruselas así que qué es lo que quieren
los auténticos break si teros pues lo
que llaman un besito duro
que reino unido no tenga que cumplir las
regulaciones europeas significa eso que
ya no podrían vender libremente europa
pues sí por supuesto y tendrían que
colocar controles fronterizos los
agricultores británicos no podrían
vender sus tomates en alemania pero
gracias a esto reino unido tendría
libertad para poder legalizar los
transgénicos si les parece bien
obviamente los tomates son solamente un
ejemplo esto afectaría a todos los
productos y diréis entonces por qué no
aprueban hombres y duro cuál es el
problema
[Música]
pues veréis porque esto es muy curioso
si reino unido fuera una sola isla pues
estaría no habría problema la isla
geográficamente hablando ya está aislada
el problema aquí ha sido que claro reino
unido no sólo reino unido también está
la parte de irlanda del norte entonces
el problema es que irlanda e irlanda del
norte tienen una frontera terrestre y os
preguntaréis y qué y dónde está el
problema pues para entenderlo nos
tenemos que ir muy atrás en el tiempo y
tenemos que hablar de u2 si de u2
atentos
[Música]
sunday bloody sunday si os gusta u2
estoy seguro de que conoceréis esta
canción sunday bloody sunday es uno de
los mejores temas de esta banda y si no
os gusta u2 pero os gusta the
cranberries y seguro que os suena una
canción que se llama zombie estas dos
canciones tienen algo en común ambas son
canciones protesta tanto sunday bloody
sunday como zombie hablan del conflicto
de irlanda del norte veréis en esta
región había dos grupos terroristas en
irak que eran católicos de izquierdas y
querían que irlanda del norte se uniera
al resto de irlanda y por el otro lado
estaba el partido unionista del ulster
que eran protestantes de derechas y
querían que irlanda del norte siguiera
formando parte del reino unido
hablamos de un conflicto que se prolongó
por 30 años y que dejó a su paso a más
de 3.500 muertos para que os hagáis una
idea eso es tres veces más que todos los
asesinados por eta en españa' un
auténtico baño de sangre que dejó
marcadas a generaciones enteras por
cierto que si queréis conocer más a
fondo todas las implicaciones del
conflicto de irlanda del norte en este
vídeo os lo explican fenomenal es de un
canal que descubierto hace poco donde
hablan de canciones poniéndolas en su
contexto histórico de verdad que os lo
recomiendo os dejo el link también en la
descripción pero lo cierto es que en el
año 1998 tony blair consiguió acabar con
este conflicto y ese fue el famoso
acuerdo de viernes santo básicamente en
este acuerdo las dos partes acordaron
que irlanda del norte sería parte del
reino unido pero que tendría una
frontera blanda con el resto de irlanda
[Música]
es decir que nunca habría un control
fronterizo y que la gente podría cruzar
el borde sin ningún problema y comerciar
viajar lo que hiciera falta
desde entonces hay miles de personas
cruzando esta frontera todos los días
como pedro por su casa un residuo
supondría romper el acuerdo del viernes
santo un acuerdo que acabó con uno de
los conflictos más negros de la zona
pero es que eso no es todo tras firmar
la paz estos dos grupos terroristas
digamos que acabaron desembocando en dos
partidos políticos por hacerlo muy claro
los partidarios del irá podríamos decir
que ahora han desembocado en lo que es
el partido del sinn fein y los
partidarios de los unionistas del ulster
digamos que ahora estar en el dup así
que ahora ya sabéis quién es esta gente
y un poco de dónde viene el dup es un
partido súper conservador que se opone
al matrimonio gay y que es
extremadamente británico vamos que para
estos tíos lo de tomarse el té a las 5
de la tarde es una religión vamos que a
su lado nuestro queridísimo simon
whistler
el que hace visual política en inglés
parece un tío de albacete son más
british que el muñequito del beefeater y
resulta que tienen 10 diputados en el
parlamento- estos 10 diputados son los
que apoyaron a mí y como os podéis
imaginar el acuerdo entre theresa may y
el dup fue extremadamente polémico no
olvidéis que muchos de sus miembros
habían estado asociados a un grupo
terrorista pero ya se sabe la política
es como es y por qué es tan importante
es todo el dup pues ahora mismo lo vamos
a ver
[Música]
las amistades peligrosas' tras fracasar
con su primer acuerdo theresa may volvió
a bruselas para negociar otro acuerdo
pero seamos honestos su propuesta seguía
siendo más de lo mismo un break si sabe
así que cuando volvió a londres la
volvieron a dar la espalda y que hizo
theresa may puedes intentarlo de nuevo
ir a bruselas a hacer cuatro cambios
cosméticos y volver a probar suerte en
londres sus compañeros de partido ya
estaban hasta la coronilla parecía que
me estaba jugando con el parlamento y
personalmente no sé muy bien si
solamente lo parecía es más incluso el
presidente de la cámara llegó a tomar
decisiones drásticas
exit john bercow descarga una tercera
votación en el mismo acuerdo básicamente
esto fue la forma educada y super
british de decir mira teresa mail vete a
tomar por culo llevas meses intentando
colar no es la misma pic propuesta y ya
no sabemos cómo decirte que no o
negociar otra cosa en bruselas o al
menos deja de darnos la tan paja a estas
alturas may ya había tenido que pedir
una prórroga a europa todavía no habían
llegado a ningún acuerdo y tenía que
seguir negociando así que en verano de
theresa may terminó por dimitir así que
de nuevo el partido conservador volvió a
hacer primarias para elegir un nuevo
primer ministro y el ganador fue este
señor que veis en pantalla
[Música]
y estamos listos para irnos el 31 de
octubre
pase lo que pase sí o sí pase lo que
pase boris johnson primer ministro de
reino unido las cosas como son
la propuesta de boris johnson para el
break sites super creativa básicamente
su idea es un break sit duro es decir
que haya controles fronterizos y como
creéis que resuelve el problema de
irlanda del norte pues muy sencillo
convirtiéndolo en una zona económica
especial básicamente los irlandeses del
norte podrían comerciar sin problemas
con el resto de los irlandeses nada
cambiaría para ellos
ahora bien el comercio entre irlanda del
norte y el resto del reino unido si
tendría que pasar una serie de controles
esta idea podría ser incluso un empujón
económico para irlanda del norte podría
convertirse en un nuevo gibraltar y
bruselas estaba encantada con ese
acuerdo y de verdad digo encantada mira
de estas imágenes y decidme si no es
hasta bonito
el propio oído que jean claude es el
jefe por aquí
tengo que decir que estoy contento con
el acuerdo pero triste por el ver éxito
pasadlo bien
pues si el acuerdo de boris johnson se
firmó de la forma más amistosa del mundo
el bueno de boris johnson estaba
convencido de que llegaría a londres y
todo el mundo le haría ahora sí señor
boris johnson eres el [ __ ] amo ven aquí
quédate que hacemos merienda-cena y te
invitamos a una cerveza por lo menos o
ese error craso error
[Música]
el parlamento de reino unido revienta
los planes de break shit de johnson en
este caso
johnson respecto a mí se quedó mucho más
cerca de ganar la votación al menos
consigue ese consenso en su partido que
may no llegó a obtener nunca entonces
cabe preguntarse qué es lo que pasó
dónde estuvo la sorpresa pues gran parte
de la respuesta la tenéis en los señores
del dup como os podéis imaginar para
estos tipos que son tan súper british
que tienen el god save the queen como
tono para el móvil
eso de que irlanda del norte tuviera un
estatus especial no les hacían ni [ __ ]
gracia
ellos quieren ser reino unido- comerciar
libremente con esos católicos irlandeses
nunca o mejor dicho nada y aquí es
cuando boris johnson vuelve a convocar
elecciones generales en reino unido por
qué pues porque le basta con conseguir
16 diputados tories más para asegurarse
que aprueben su presión y en principios
encuestas a día de grabación de este
vídeo dicen que la jugada le puede salir
bien de hecho el doctor irlandés puede
que desaparezca incluso
lamento británico algo parecido pasa con
otros partidos pequeños los
conservadores más leales a johnson
tienen todas las papeletas de ganar a
estas elecciones pero por otra parte
todos sabemos que las encuestas pueden
fallar más que una escopeta de feria así
que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros
que os gustaría que pasara os parece
bien que reino unido se vaya de europa
lo antes posible
o tal vez preferiría es un nuevo
referéndum creéis que boris johnson va a
salir victorioso de estas elecciones
podeis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios
y también momento spam podéis pasaros
por mi canal donde además justo acabo de
subir un vídeo sobre los conceptos clave
en el tema del break si de explicándolo
un poquito más en detalle y como siempre
recordad que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribiros a visual
polític y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]